دكتور لقاء بهذه الملاحظه اذا كان اذا كان
ما يجري هو انتقام لمقتل الجنود
الامريكيين في في
الاردن فلماذا اليمن لماذا هذه الضربه
المكثفه التي شملت اكثر من
36 هدفا في 13 موقعا وفق البيان الامريكي
البريطاني المشترك ما الرساله
هنا اعتقد ان الامر يتعلق
بمحاوله استرضاء الداخل الامركي فيما يتصل
بايران خلال الايام الاخيره تحديدا بعد
العمليه التي جرت يوم الاحد الماضي فجر
الاحد ضد القاعده الامريكيه كان هناك هجوم
شديد على على بايدن طبعا لاغراض انتخابيه
بالدرجه الاساس من قبل المعسكر الجمهوري
ومنه ترامب اتهامه بانه هو الذي فرط
بارواح الجنود الامريكان وبانه لم يستطع
حمايه المصالح الامريكيه ومنح ايران
الكثير من الفرص وحتى
الاموال وبالتالي هو الذي سمح بذلك ربما
اراد بايدن ان يثبت انه قادر على مواجهه
ايران وتحدي الايراني ضده في المنطقه هذا
من ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه قد يكون فيه ايضا
رساله شديده اللهجه لايران بان هناك رغبه
قدره امريكيه قدره من اداره بايدن على
ايذاء كل اذرع ايران في المنطقه ب فيها
اليمن بطريقه حازمه وحاسه ان استمرت ايران
بارسال رسائل خشنه كما جرى في القاعده
بالاردن لا ننسى ان هناك ضراع الاهم
لايران هو حزب الله اللبناني هذا هو
الوحيد اللي حتى الان لم يتعرض لاي هجوم
ولا اظن انه سيتعرض على الاقل في المدى
المنظور من قبل الولايات المتحده لان هذا
امر مختلف وسياق مختلف وسيك يكون مستوى
مختلف لكن ربما تستغل
اسرائيل هذه العمليات كلها لتصعيد النزاع
مع حزب الله وتوريط الولايات المتحده في
صراع اكبر واشمل في الشرق الاوسط وهو ما
تريده الحقيقه تريده من اجل الخروج من
المازق فشلها في غزه وبالتالي جعل هذه
الحرب حرب الغرب ضد حماس وضد من يؤيدها
وبالتالي سيكون هناك دعم لاسرائيل هذه
المره ما يتجاوز حدود السلاح الى الدعم
الفعلي بالقتال هذا الامر ربما يحصل حقيقه
لانه الان المنطقه على شفى هاويه حقيقيه
هذا النمط من العمليات في سياق حرب غزه
العنيفه التي يعني الهبت مشاعر الناس في
المنطقه بشكل كبير جدا اعتقد ان مثل هذه
العمليات ولا سما انها قد تستمر حسب
الاعلان الامريكي هي لن تكون مقتصره على
ضربه واحده يمكن ان تستمر لايام وربما
اسابيع او حتى اكثر مثل هذه الامور خصوصا
ان تطورت الى عمليات اغتيال تدمير لمواقع
في العواصم والمدن الكبرى اظن انه يمكن ان
يؤدي الى
تصعيد الموقف بشكل كبير جدا ولا اشك ابدا
انه سيكون هناك يعني ربما وصول حقيقه الى
حافه الحرب وربما استهداف واقع امريكيه في
مناطق خارج السياق المعروف في بغداد
وسوريا في العراق وسوريا ربما تشمل مواقع
اخرى للمصالح الامريكيه في الشرق الاوسط
عموما وهذا سيجر دول اخرى الى الصراع من
دون ان يكون لها دخل بما يجري حاليا